how does DC and Marvel's Trinity
parallel with the Unholy Trinity of the
Book of Revelation the dragon the Beast
and the false prophet Thor was cast out
of Heaven to Earth like a bolt of
lightning he parallels Satan just like
Batman is a parallel to Satan he's the
god of the underworld Hades bman is
Hades his iconography is that of a demon
Iron Man Iron represents Rome which
parallels with the Beast of Revelation
Wonder Woman John the Revelator was
wondering after the Harlot dressed in
Scarlet Iron Man and Wonder Woman
represent Rome which is the Beast
Captain America obviously represents
America and Superman he's the truth and
the Justice in the American way and the
false prophet is America when you look
at DC and Marvel's Trinity you have
Satan the Beast and the false prophet
check out the video for more details
mind bone
[Music]